j'étais en vacances au Club Med avec ma
fille et sa maman et et on m'a déroulé
le tapis rouge et on m'a dit est-ce que
vous accepteriez de dîner à la table du
directeur
j'avais fait deux films et demi ils sont
vraiment hyper cinéphile au Club Med
quand même donc j'ai et puis
effectivement arrivé à la table
directement et on me dit alors comment
on se remette tout ça je me dis bah
quand même 10 millions d'entrées ou je
sais pas c'est et en fait il m'avait
confondu effectivement avec Samy la
série et j'ai passé tout le dîner à lui
faire croire que j'étais effectivement
sa menaceri que j'avais joué dans le
taxi et ça a été une semaine un peu ce
qui est un peu embarrassant c'était un
peu embarrassé
j'ai pas su reculer je crois que j'ai
aimé ce tapis rouge donc
[Musique]